Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday
morning podcast from Monday,
April 29th, 2013 how
are ya? How you doing?
I am in a fucking phenomenal mood.
Absolutely.
I'm in a great goddamn mood.
You know why? You know why?
Because I'm not even mad right now that
my cell phone is ringing this fucking
early in the podcast. I'm not. I'm not.
Um,
you know what's funny?
That's cell phone just made me
completely lose my train of thought.
That's how simplistic my brain is. It goes
in a straight line. One fucking thing,
knocks it off track. And I just,
I, I forget where I was going.
Why am I in a great mood? Oh, I know why.
Because the Celtics showed that they
have fucking high and the Lakers lost,
got swept, disgraced, humiliated,
and I loved every God damn second of it.
You know? And you know why I am I okay,
I'm back on track. I feel fucking
vindicated after all these Laker fans.
You know what? T tweeting me,
Facebooking me, my spacing,
me friends during me saying
that I'm just a hater, you know,
which is the classic thing that somebody
says when they can't refute any points
that you made. They go,
are you just a hater?
Is when I told them that the guy that
they kept constantly sit there and call
and chant MVP yet is is a
fucking cancer on that team,
so fucking cancer and they just can't see
it because I'm not saying all of them,
but just because they see that everybody
plays. He's fantasy fucking football,
baseball, bullshit, all
they look at his stats.
All right,
let me tell you something. Laker
fans, when you're not eating your pot,
cookies and body fucking boogie
boarding or whatever the fuck it is,
you guys do get up when you're not
laying back at the chair with the fucking
dental office getting
botox in your fucking head,
even though you're only 19 years old,
why don't you just put yourself in the
position of the other players on the
Lakers?
All right.
To wake the fuck up,
get out of the sun,
stopped frying up your goddamn brain.
It just use a little bit of common sense.
Listen,
I know after the games,
when Colby walks off with 10
seconds left during a loss,
cause he got his 37 points,
you know that afterwards when they asked
the other Lakers in front of the camera
and they go, Oh, you know,
how did you feel about that?
And then they just go, well,
you know, uh, Colby, he's uh,
he's a competitor. You know,
he's one of the best that I ever played
the gay bed. Uh, I mean he wants to wait.
I mean,
we all do add a,
that didn't happen tonight on fortunately
and all we know what to do is to just
keep it.
I can fucking do it.
You just keep working hard and
digital law have any sort of a,
did it annoy you at all? We walked off
core. Nope. No, it didn't bother me. Uh,
you know, every guy has a
different personality. I mean,
you can just fucking gracefully navigate
that minefield and just say all that
bullshit.
I would fucking give $1 million if I
had it to listen to the other liquors on
the team,
their cell phone conversations,
when they leave the staple center
talking to their fucking Bro,
you know, going all Paul Mccartney
and John Lennon, fucking sick sec.
You know that coming out of there and
they fucking range rovers and they fucking
$100,000 Mercedes just driving outgoing.
Can you fucking believe that mother
fuckers? Why they get fucked?
You know I'm wide open. Wide Open
coffee. Write it. Write it. Yeah.
Fuck God takes a turn around jumper
with three guys hanging off on 10 feet
behind the arc.
Okay,
I don't care.
I'm telling you right now, do
what the fuck would you do? Okay.
If you were at some four h club and
you're supposed to build a tree fort,
you know, and you hold up the board and
you're supposed to hammer in both sides.
One conscious hammers and his side,
they just fucking walks away.
The whole thing collapses out of the
tree and he just walks away and everybody
else at camp is laughing at you during
the loss and he's fucking already backing
the popsicle stick in the fucking
log cabin. How would you feel?
What would you be saying?
You know?
Okay.
I'll tell you,
if it was televised around the fucking
world to all the four H's and your goal
was to continue being in four h is you
do exactly what the other fucking lake or
people do. You just sit there
going like, well, you know, uh,
he's uh,
he loves building tree forts and a,
it's really in his heart and when things
don't go well, he gets upset and uh,
you know,
all we know how to do is just to get out
there tomorrow actually you put voice
would be way higher
and I try to build a tree fort.
I love it. So the guy, he
gets injured. All right,
now you can actually sit down.
It may be watched the Lakers you get
maybe get to watch Steve Nash do what the
fuck he does.
Distribute the Goddamn ball rather than
pass it to Colby and then sit there.
You know, I dunno what, what do you do
with that after you've passed it to Colby?
I mean, your wives, we'll
just fucking sit down.
You don't take a little
cat nap or whatever.
I was actually looking forward to that
shit. And what happens? What happened?
What is the cancer? Have it
big. What does this guy do?
He starts tweeting during the game,
criticizing the fucking coach like a
fence. You can't read through the lines.
When his coach said, uh, he's
a fan now. That's what fans do.
And then Colby like laughs it off.
That right read between the lines.
He's saying this guy's one of the biggest
cons I've ever had a coach in my life.
Even when he's on the court, he's still
fucking up the chemistry of the tape.
All right.
Did Bill Russell ever tweet during
his Celtic career? All right,
you get the point. You know what
I'm saying? I feel vindicated.
And how about those Celtics,
about those old ass Celtics?
I was really nervous
that they were going out,
that they were going to get swept and uh,
I dunno,
I, I, I gotta be honest with you. I didn't
watch one second of the Celtic series.
I've, I, I can only pick
one sport, you know,
so I've been watching the Bruins
and I gotta tell you, man,
I have never been so fucking
frustrated with the team in my life.
Jesus Christ, the first two periods would
come out. We play great play, great.
We always score every
fucking game I watched,
we score to fucking goals and we look
phenomenal until right towards the end of
the second period or the third period
and the whole thing just falls apart.
I don't know what's going
on. I, I'm actually,
I just think it's one of these years,
one of these years where you can, I,
there's no way.
I can't figure out what the problem is.
Nobody can figure out what the problem
is and unfortunately somebody is going to
have to pay for it because when
you don't get where you want to be,
either the coach has to lose his job
or somebody has to get fucking traded.
Um, I dunno, it was like watching the, uh,
I mean this is obviously not as bad,
but a few years ago when the Red Sox,
when the wheels fell off with them and
rather than everybody just sitting down
and being like, all right,
we won to world series.
We obviously know what the
fuck we're doing. Okay,
let's try to figure this thing out.
Everybody started pointing fingers and
the whole fucking thing disintegrates.
And it was like watching
van Halen breakup, you know,
David Lee Roth left van Halen brothers
go over this way, you know, and,
and are they better for it?
Did they ever make a better
album than those first? What,
four or five they never did. They never
did cause they fucked with the chemistry.
Um, so anyways, this is
the Monday morning podcast.
I'm your wonderful house bill burr and a,
I got a buddy of mine up and coming
comedian Danny Lobell has an, uh,
has a new comedy album that's coming out.
This isn't a commercial,
this is just some, just a nice little
promotion for a friend of mine. Uh,
the name of the album's called some
kind of comedian, um, April 30th,
tomorrow. The album, unless you
listen to this years in the future,
then it's already out. But if you listen
to it today, April 30th, tomorrow,
Tuesday 2013,
April 30th,
the album is out in stores and it'll
be on iTunes, amazon.com, et cetera.
It's recorded in Scotland,
which I think is cool. You know,
it gives it a nice different flavor
at the, uh, Glasgow Comedy Festival.
Danny labelle's called some kind of
comedian. Uh, check it out if you want.
What's great? It's as if it's on
iTunes. You can listen to some tracks.
If you like it, you could download
it. If you don't, you don't have to,
but either way,
don't fucking start bitching at me.
I liked this guy and I think he's funny.
Okay, go fuck yourselves. All right.
Back to the podcast.
Um, where the hell am I?
What's the hell would I want to talk about
after going on and on about that?
You know,
I've been reading this Daily Mail thing.
You guys go on this website wants
to deal with Daily Mail. Um,
did I already get rid of
it? Oh No. There it is.
This is the most insane fucking website.
They just got it.
They got it. I love it.
They've got stories all around.
They got one here. This,
this is a bad one.
Boy.
Two and 10 month old brother died after
exhausted Australian mother left them in
the shower and fell asleep for 10 hours.
Jesus Christ. What the fuck was she on?
Huh?
I was really tired and I slept for 10.
You don't sleep for 10 hours unless you've
been doing what? Blow for three days.
I guess some people could sleep that long.
That's fucking,
I mean, I know. I shouldn't
be laughing at this shit.
That's a bad one. Then they got this
other story. It says you've got a,
you've got a friend in me,
Xena the warrior puppy rescued
as it was starving to death.
Now changing the life of an autistic boy
and you got to see this picture of this
dog when they found it starving.
It looks like a fossil with fur on it.
It already looks like it's dead.
Somehow this thing comes back to life
and is now helping this kid that has
autism. All right, so there's
one for your cat people.
You have a phone and a, she created
fossil looking fucking cat. All right.
And you nursed it back to health,
giving it milk and whatever and a little
box for it to shit in the house and
give you that look like, yeah, you deal
with it like cats always do. All right.
Do you think at the end of that journey
that it would then fucking help out some
autistic kid you think a cat cat doesn't
have a fucking ability to do that?
You know, they don't cause
there were a bunch of cops.
So there you go to the two
debates have ended today.
Dogs are better people than cats.
And the Celtics have more heart than
the Lakers. That's just it. Okay.
And I'm also gonna, I'm also gonna fucking
checkoff. Colby is not the fucking MVP.
All right? Colby is if it fantasy
football, fantasy basketball,
that's the fucking guy you
want your God damn team.
He's not even in the game.
Any still affecting.
He's got to sit there and
tweet and criticize his own
goddamn coach. Oh my God,
that guy earns the K, you know, and can't,
um,
all right onto some other shit here.
And I know it's been a lot of,
oh, it's been pretty much nothing.
Nothing but sports talk this week.
Uh,
this one actually transcends sports to
show that everybody in sports is not a
fucking meathead NBA star.
Jason Collins comes out as gay,
making them him the first
openly homosexual athlete
on a major American sports
teeth. Now other people have come out,
but always after their careers. And uh,
and I think it's fucking great.
I've said for years I wanted it to be a
football player who was the most fucking
like,
like a ray Lewis level guy.
I always thought that that would
be fucking hilarious just because,
not all,
because it's just an extra level of way
to talk shit to fans of the other team,
you know,
which I guess is probably homophobic
to be like even at gay guys kicking the
shit out of you. You know, like this
is not some tough Gig dudes out there.
So look at this. I'm learning
things too. Here it is. NBA start.
Jason Collins came out as gay
today in a revealing interview,
but how many people are
going to lose their jobs?
Trying to write a Twitter
joke about this one, um,
or their endorsement with some
fucking insurance company,
making him the first professional
athlete in American sports, uh,
to come out as gay. I want
somebody else's as a soccer player.
Come now. Oh Jesus. That's
an easy joke right there.
I'm not going to step in that fucking
minefield. I'm not going to do it.
I'm going to be mature.
Throughout this entire story.
The 34 year old basketball player opened
up an interview with sports illustrated
amid much speculation about rumors that
the major athlete would be coming out of
the closet.
Uh,
the initial reports came from the
national football league as a number of
straight players said that they would
support a teammate should they reveal they
were gay? Yeah. Why wouldn't you?
I got to tell you the showers gotta
be a little weird then, you know.
Okay,
it's this, is this fucking dumb. Should
they have their own showers then?
Or at least play pay a cover if
they're going to go into the shot,
should they have to, I'm going to
open this debate with my own moron.
Should they have to pay a cover charge
when they go into the shower with
everybody else, with all the other
dudes and the team, you know,
I mean, what the fuck? What
if I was playing in Wnb Ba?
They wouldn't let me go in the shower.
He's gonna walk in there with this.
Right.
They would all be flipping out.
Yeah.
That's a fucking very ignorant yet.
Interesting point.
You know,
everybody on your team is in shape.
They're all got their abs and that pex
go and you can't tell me that's not a
fucking enjoyable experience.
They would like be like me if I got
to walk in and shower with all these
Victoria secret models
and they'll be like, whoa,
I'm just like,
Yo.
I also like wearing high
shoes with fatness. Right?
I Dunno. Either way. I'm fucking
around. I think it's great.
It's about God the up time and uh,
I think it's fucking hilarious
because there's so many morons.
They're to sports fans that I
wished that I was in a sports bar
when this came out and just watching
fucking guys eyebrows and fucking getting
all twisted up. Well, it's sports.
You're not supposed to be gay. Um,
I think it's great. Good for him.
Good on him. Who's he play
for right now? I never 30.
All the Washington wizards come
out as gay. Oh my God. Did they,
they didn't make the playoffs or not?
I have no idea.
I have no idea. But I can
guarantee fucking tee you somebody,
somebody is going to lose their job.
Trying to make a joke
or somebody going to a
out Jesus,
you know,
all those Bible belt people via ever
plays a game down in like fucking,
he plays the grizzly. They going to
be standing outside the team bus.
You are going to hey l,
that's when you know you're a moron.
When you, when you're fucking,
you make one syllable words,
two syllable, you're going to hey. Oh,
he's in yard.
Um,
what's the one? And then I always
do the one about the chick.
I can't fucking remember
my is fried people.
I've been on the road this entire month.
Actually,
this entire fucking year I figured
it out and I can't even remember.
The numbers were like something like 17
or 18 weeks into this year and I've been
to like 20 cities. All right. I really
don't know what's going on in the world.
This is how fucking out of the loop I am.
I knew that there was an explosion
in Texas and it took me two,
three days before I,
I read something that let me know whether
it was an accident or another fucking
Timothy Mcveigh Psycho.
All right. So I do the,
um, I do the, uh, what did I do?
I did Dallas. I'll take you through
my week. What was it Wednesday?
The fuck is today. My, I don't even know.
So Wednesday or Thursday
I went to Las Vegas, um,
and I did a private show.
They to go,
you've got a private show in uh,
in Vegas.
And I didn't even ask who the
fuck it was for. I was like, Oh,
I'm making some money. Yeah, I'll
go to Vegas. Oh, walk around.
I'll take a fucking steam.
It's one of my,
the only time I ever take a steam is when
I go to Las Vegas cause every fucking
casino has one.
And
it's the greatest fucking experience
of your life. You know, you walk in,
first of all, everybody in there was
always like 80 years old. For some reason.
Old Guys love taking it to stay. The
only time you have a fucking go in there,
right?
So I always go in there and uh,
you got to go in there.
Also would like an extra towel because
as you're sweating the impurities out,
all the impurities are
sitting on your skin.
And if you don't fucking white towel off,
you just absorb them back in.
Or a lot of them, the ones that
don't drip off of you or whatever,
so you fucking go in there,
you have a great God damn time,
you in some other like fucking guy looks
like Mr. Hooper from fucking sesame
street,
you know?
Yeah.
And uh, you come out, you
fucking pores are open,
your fucking shave.
You're not gonna have to shave for like
another three days unless you're one of
those Harry Apes. And uh, then he'd
go upstairs, you take a fucking nap,
you sleep like a goddamn
baby. Right. Unfortunate.
I came in too late so I wasn't able
to do all this. Um, so anyways,
typical me like an asshole.
I'm one of those,
some comedian comedians
are really organized.
And then you have other comedians like
myself where as I'm going to the airport,
any the NEA or the taxi guys go on. What
airline? I'm looking it up in my phone.
Um, so I get there and I go,
who am I doing this, this, uh,
this private show for?
And they said, oh, it's a,
it's a poker tournament
with a bunch of oil men.
Yeah,
there's like 10 billionaires.
The rest are millionaires and there's a
couple of bankers there. Right. So we are,
I am now feeling like fucking Beyonce,
you know,
when she performed for those dictators
after all my time talking about,
uh, you know, blood money and all
that shit. Here I am going out there,
I should have put on a little glitter
dress and dance like a fucking whore and I
go out to go do this benefit.
Okay.
Right. Cause I just said
yes because I saw the money.
So right now all my credibility,
you know,
beyond me being a moron is out the window
at this point because I still did the
Gig, right? So I go down
and I do the Gig and uh,
I got the funniest,
weirdest fucking applause break.
I actually had a great time and I enjoyed
afterwards I was shooting the shit
with a couple and they
will fucking hilarious,
like just their whole perspective being
in Hollywood that is so God damn liberal
to then perform for these oil men. And
you know they're talking about, you know,
I was making fun of him talking
about fracking and lack what
it works. I don't give a shit, you know,
poisons the water Ziploc.
I drink it
and they're all laughing and I made some
sort of reference to a bird covered in
oil and then I just started
doing this rednecky character.
Well what the fuck?
You know what a flag get out of the oil.
You dumb mother fucker dude.
Applause break.
I love they are going to get mad.
I was going to break in their balls.
They thought it was fucking hilarious.
And this doesn't make them any worse than
anybody else that just like everybody
I meet on the road,
they are 100% immersed in the deal that
makes them still be able to put fruit
loops on the table. So anything positive
about it, they fucking love. And, and I,
that's what I've found.
That's what I've learned to traveling
is that people love their own deal and
they think that their deal is the only
deal. And it's the only way to go.
And anybody who's against it is a
fucking cunt. And that includes clouds,
the most liberal fucking
people on the planet. You know,
if you listened to liberals talking about
police officers and that type of shit,
like they, they do like
reverse Fox News, you know.
So, so I did that Gig and, uh,
had a fucking great time.
And then I flew to Dallas the next day.
Did,
um, did a youtube video, made one of
those tours of the city, had a great time.
They're fucking show was amazing.
Crowds were unbelievable.
It's combinations of crowds being
unbelievable. And I've done so many shows,
so I'm really on my fucking game, you
know, I'm not like going up there,
shaking the rust off,
trying to figure out what comes next.
I've just been on my fucking game and,
um,
okay.
So he, okay, wait,
I remember what I was talking about trying
to get to like how out of the loop I
am. So I'm driving down, it's
me versus me and Tom Lewis,
the guy, oh, films, all of
my, uh, tours of cities.
We're driving down to Austin,
Texas going down the 35 east bound
and down loaded up [inaudible] um,
okay.
And Tom, Tom's like this fucking
like, he just researches everything.
So we're on our way
down. He goes, he's like,
this is insane bakery cause me and dumb
Paul Versey we were just going to go to,
when I hop, you know, get
pigs in a blanket, it's just,
you know, whip cream Montes,
dumb shit. You could get 10 feet
from your own house, you know.
So he goes, no, he goes,
if you guys can just hang in
there another 10 minutes away,
it's this place called the check shop,
like checklists Vivaki and they
have these fucking insane, um,
breakfast foods and all this type of
shit. Right. So we go down there and, um,
okay,
I walk in there.
Okay.
And I can instantly tell us not a chain
or maybe there's a couple left. I Dunno.
Maybe it is a chain. I have no
fucking idea. I go in there.
All I know is I see a bunch of locals
sitting there standing in line blinds out
the fucking door basically and I'm like,
all right,
this is going to be some good shit.
And they make all like these
little like breakfast sandwiches.
I'm trying to find this thing
here and this is what I ordered.
I ordered a hot chubby with cheese
and I have not been able to
say that without laughing.
I snickered when I ordered it.
It was a spicy sausage and like this,
this honey bun with like cheese in there
and a little checks bakery and this is
what, this is what it's right in Waco
or water Texas. I'm a fucking moron.
I'm sitting there and I'm watching all
these people walking in there like three,
four,
five people dressed all in black,
red ribbons and I'm going and I'm
sitting there eating with Versie. Right.
A couple of more on sitting there.
Girl.
These people either just came
from a wedding or a funeral.
I'm guessing it's a funeral. Look at
that. Look at misery on their face.
And then Tom gets in the car and he tells
us that we're literally like an eighth
of a mile from where the
fucking place exploded.
I've never felt so
fucking dumb in my life.
Like this is like one of the
biggest stories in the country.
I'm sitting here an
eighth of a mile from it.
People will come in from funerals for
loved ones and I'm eating a fucking spicy
chubby would cheese go?
That guy looks kind of sad.
My face actually turned
red from embarrassment,
embarrassment of my own fucking stupidity.
Um,
fucking horrific. There's
no, there's no really,
there's nothing funny about that story.
What are basically asking you guys,
why do you tune in every week if you're
going to listen to somebody this dumb.
All right.
And with that asking you why you tune
in every week we got some advertising,
a legal zoom.com.
Everybody. All right, look,
you got to have a plan for your future.
You do financial planning,
you get insurance. Uh, but
to get to peace of mind,
you've got to make sure your
family is also legally protected.
So where do you turn for
affordable legal protection?
You can trust simple legal
zoom.com for up to 12 years.
They've been helping Americans get
personalized wills, power of attorney,
legal trust and real estate documents
and more legal zoom also helped start and
maintain businesses within
corporations and LLC filings,
trademarks and copyrights.
The whole deal there.
Timesaving time saving
service was developed by a
team of experienced attorneys
and legal zoom takes care
of you from stat to finish.
Legal Zoom documents is one
of the greatest points here.
Legal Zoom documents have been accepted
by courts and government agencies in all
50 states. All right. Legal Zoom
is not a law firm, but they can be.
They can contact you,
whoops. They can connect you,
sorry to an attorney and provide self
help services at your specific direction.
For even more savings.
Enter Bur bur r in the
referral box at checkout.
If you're a parent or an entrepreneur,
don't wait any longer.
Call or visit legal zoom.com and
protect what's yours. All right,
there's one Z and here's
number two, z. You all know it.
I don't know how many times they got to
keep saying it. People sit down today,
look in the mirror and
ask yourself one question,
why do I keep going to the post office?
Why would I keep going to the post office
when I can do everything at home with
what bill?
What can I use?
stamps.com stamps.com you'll never
have to go to the post office again.
It's phenomenal.
You get,
you can get official US postage for
any letter or package using your own
computer and printer. Uh, no need for
one of those expensive postage meters.
stamps.com offers more features than
a meter at a fraction of the cost.
No hidden fees or longterm
meter commitments.
Save up to 80% compared to a meter plus
you'll never have to go to the post
office again. In fact, stamps.com
offers special postage discounts.
You can get even you can't
even get at the post office.
I use stamps.com to send
out all my DVDs and I,
ladies and gentlemen am a moron.
If I can figure out how to use
that scale and use my printer,
you can too. So don't be intimidated
if you're an Oldie like me right now,
use my last name bur bur
for the special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus
offer includes a digital
scale and up to $55 free
postage. Don't wait. Go to stamps.com
before you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeandburburthatstamps.com
and to
ber. All righty. That was
painless and he said was,
well you had to listen to my reading, so
I guess you know, and I go fuck yourself.
Uh, let me close this out here. Yes,
I don't want to save that.
And when you download stuff like this,
does it slow down your computer after?
Well,
should I be like a racing these
reads every week? Um, all right,
let's get to some questions for
this week. Everybody. Um, dear bill,
really enjoy your humor in the podcast.
Well thank you very much.
That's very kind to you.
But please stop telling people to pay
off their homes and to not refinance when
the bank calls with the new loan vehicle
that saves them money and is a no
brainer. I am a real
estate appraiser. Oh what?
Of course you are you
country or in the business.
If these people stop refinancing,
I'll be out of a job. Oh I get it now.
I just turned 50 and have no other skills.
So unless that I can open for
you on the road. What he say.
We take it easy on this fragile economy
and keep a lid on the unemployment.
Thanks.
So to save your job,
you want me to look the other way and
tell all these people to fucking refinance
and even though this six,
seven years into their mortgage,
you want me to start them right back at
the beginning at payment number one for
30 years,
you know,
at least there with all that front end
had loaded interest started all over
again. You know, you kind
of blaming the victims here.
I don't understand how we all ended
up under the thumb of these bankers.
I could,
if they initially started off with a
mixed martial art training and then after
they won the championship,
they then got into banking.
Then I could see why everyone
would be so afraid of bankers.
But the fact that they're just a bunch
of pencil pushing Jack was the last time
you saw a tough banker.
And I'm not saying they're not out there
cause I know I'll get emails. Dude,
you see this guy down at the local branch.
This kid could glide pro at left fucking
tackle, but he blew out his knee.
Um, what are you actually
trying to tell me that,
that it doesn't save them money.
That's, that's the illusion of it.
It lowers your, your, your
mortgage payment for the month,
but it prolongs your interest
and in the long haul.
Okay.
You ended up paying way more money and
you're asking me to co sign off on like
years more of indentured servitude to
these banker cons. I can't do that.
I have ethics. I do private
shows for oil, men and bankers.
Listen, sir, if you could tell me, if you
can write me back. Let's, let's summit.
We'll make this a two pipe.
If you could write me back and tell me how
that's saving them money
and don't do that. Well,
they were paying two grand a month for
their mortgage and now their minimum
payment is 1700 so it's 300 off.
I want you to do, do the math,
go through the 30 years of it and
their interest and all that. Okay?
You're not going to be able to write me
back and say that they're saving money.
They're not. It's a fuck over and it's
a very easy fuck over to read that.
When the bank reaches out to you and says,
Hey, you want to save money? Hey listen,
we were sitting here trying to figure
out how we could make less money off of
you. It's a fuck over. All right.
I've already done my
filthy Dade this week.
Tap dancing for a bunch of
fucking oil men. You know,
I would've fucking my kid. What
am I supposed to do, you know?
Do you have I come up with some
sort of alternative fucking source
to help your car going?
I Dunno, whatever, sir.
I'm one of the biggest hypocrites you're
ever going to find. I know your deal.
You want people to refinance
so they could what?
Continue making their debt payments.
Listen,
whether I tell them to do that or not,
like none of the laws got changed and
the banks got these houses back to do it
all over again.
I told you that story a few weeks ago,
but the guy who sold me my house, he goes,
dude, you bought it the perfect time.
You can get like another 50 grand
for your house if you sold it today.
He goes to, market's exploding. And he
goes, I've never seen anything like this.
It's like, what are you talking about?
Even selling houses for 10 years,
you lived through the fucking
biggest bubble ever and I, you know,
Oh yeah. You think so? He doesn't
give a fuck. They don't give a fuck.
So don't fucking come at me with your
hat in your hand and talk about this
fragile economy when you know
what you're doing out there.
Right with your fucking
three card Monte Jesus.
That got a little fucking got a little,
a little chippy.
All right. Hair loss or sex loss bill,
I'm sure you've heard of Propecia.
Heard of it.
I used it.
I used it and when I ran out of it,
I just had that honest moment
with myself and I was just like,
there's no way. There's not going to be
a side effect. Okay, there's always this,
there's no way. There's just no way.
There's no way this thing, okay,
I'll save my hair but damage my liver.
You know,
what do I need more? You know, a full head
of hair or a functioning fucking liver.
You just, you know, you just got to bite
the bullet and turn it. Just turn old.
Just age gracefully, you know?
I try to keep my hair short.
I tried to offend as little people as
I go through the slow process of seeing
what my skull actually looks like.
He goes,
I have a lot of friends on it
that say it's sort of works.
Definitely slows down hair loss
by doing something. However,
apparently the drawbacks is no boner.
Oh,
is that, I don't know either way on that
one. That's a, that's some bar stuff.
I think that at that can,
that can happen to some people.
Yeah.
I have no fucking idea.
He said,
so do you choose hair to
get sex or choose no hair,
which might mean no sex.
Is this some sort of sick joke by the
pharmaceutical companies know you're,
you're fighting nature. Listen
Dude, I'll tell you right now.
All right, there's women out there
that think a shaved head is sexy.
Not all of them, but
there's enough. All right,
there's enough out there that you can
keep going up. Bang. And women, you know,
some women find a shaved head fucking
they lay like it turns him on.
So listen,
this is the great thing about women is
they could see beyond what you look like.
Okay?
If you come in there and you got a little
swagger and you're funny and you're
fucking, you know, shaved head shows
confidence, dude. You're like, fuck it.
Preemptive strike. You guys are
walking out on me. Well you know what,
I'm kicking you out the door
and you take out your clippers.
You know, I bust my head down a few
years ago. I fucking loved it, man.
I took all the jokes. When your kid's a
patient, a fucking make a wish. But bubba,
it Peters out after a couple of weeks,
you know,
I dunno, I go back and forth.
I go back and forth. I, I mean,
I go literally from doing,
maybe I'll do the fucking hair transplant
to all the way back to all fucking
shape my head again. I have no idea, but
I gotta be honest with you, dude. It,
it doesn't you, the vibe you're
bringing is going to be way more.
Listen,
do you really want to get with some
girl who's with you because you have a
fucking, a nice big cow lick
on top of your fucking head.
And if you didn't have it then she
wouldn't be with you. You know,
going bald is like driving
a piece of shit car.
It really keeps the horse away from you.
All these fucking idiots was full heads
of hair driving around flashy cars.
You see what happens to them
and what happened to Mel Gibson?
He should have just gone bald,
but he didn't.
He kept fighting it through and shit
up there. Drove around in a flashy car.
I had to give up my fucking
lacquer tickets, you know,
flipping out, flipping up.
You know what dude? Yeah.
Don't take those fucking drugs.
Those drugs are brand new and the side
effects that they're talking about,
I'm telling you is just the shit that
they're letting on to cover their ass is
that they said that there
was some side effects. Okay.
From what I've overheard bars,
the people on the FDA,
half of them used to work for these
pharmaceutical fucking company.
So they got the nuts running
the fucking nuthouse. All right,
and you're just going to be a gay,
you're going to be a little lab rat if
you start taking that shit. All right?
So I would suggest not doing it.
Let nature take its fucking
course and do what I'm doing.
Wait for the cure and our
guarantee at ain't going to come.
So just fucking man up and go bald your
fucking pussy gate. Do what I'm doing.
Just slowly let it happen.
A year from now,
I'm going to have fucking hair plugs
and I'm going to be performing for
dictators for New Year's
Eve, New Year's Eve. Oh,
it'd be best friends with Beyonce.
I didn't see my itinerary either.
I didn't know who it was.
I literally use the same excuse
for performing for oilman.
Um, anyways, loner a,
their red haired reindeer.
Um,
love everything you do and
listen to you as your, as you,
as changed my life. Oh Jesus. All right.
Now this one isn't going to be on.
Make love everything you do and listening
to you has, oh, has changed my life.
Sorry. That is on me. However,
although I am more comfortable being
myself now than I was before I listened to
you, I've got a dilemma. I don't know why,
but I don't leave a lasting
impression on people. Oh God, dude,
that's one of the saddest things ever.
You just said you're forgettable.
Hey, you know what you should do? You
should turn to a life of crime. You know,
don't hurt anybody.
Just going with an unloaded gun and
start robbing convenience stores, right?
Get the money you'd take off and
then fucking when the cops come.
Can you give us a description?
Yeah.
You know that this is a funny
thing about him. You know, he just,
I don't know if it's cause I was so scared
or the fact that he just was just so
forgettable. I okay. He,
I know he had an arm because he was
in a hand because he was holding a,
anyways, I go to a community
college and for some unknown reason,
my personality doesn't attract anyone.
I lost all my friends from high school,
they all moved on with their lives and
the people in my college don't notice me.
I'm very eccentric. Jesus Christ. Dude,
you sound like you should
be on some list here, man.
Please tell me that you're not going to
fucking start reading about chemicals.
All right?
He goes at work.
Everyone loves my crazy ass
personality and my spontaneity.
But these two spaces are such liars.
They always say, oh, we should hang out.
But every Monday I always hear about these
stories of them going out without me.
I've tried to make plans, but
they easily flake. Please, Bill,
your podcast keeps me sane and you
can only make sense of this. Um,
ps.
You know that polite fake personality
everyone has when they first meet someone.
What if a girl has that personality
only around you and no one else?
Is she uncomfortable with you
or likes you? Oh, Jesus. Dude,
Jesus.
All right.
Oh fuck.
How do I fucking cut?
Why do I,
how do I react to this fucking
atmosphere without burning up? Um,
listen, this is what you gotta do. Okay?
You can't give a fuck whether people
hang out with you, but not all right?
I, if I, if I had to guess, I'd say
maybe you're trying too hard. You know,
take a deep breath.
Just fucking relax.
Come in on Monday and say what's up
to people and go about your business.
That's what I would do. All right?
And stop trying to hang out with them,
you know, and take this new
fucking relaxed approach.
Go into a bar and just big chill.
Don't have a crazy ass personality
and be spontaneity spontaneous,
because I think I'm reading into that
you're trying too hard and you're freaking
people out. Just fucking show. All right?
Just fucking chill out and relax. If that
girl is a fake personality around you,
that does not mean she likes you.
I think you're freaking
people out a little bit.
I'm not trying to criticize you here.
I think he just trying too hard because
the fact that your friends from high
school took off from you. You might be,
you might be a little self conscious.
So now you're questioning who you are
and you're trying to fucking amp ramp up
to this energy level that
you're not normally at. So it's,
it's weird and people out. So I
would just fucking chill, you know?
But please do not fucking go to work
and do something crazy because there's a
lot of that shit in there that made me
fucking worried about you. All right.
Just fucking let me tell you. Just
like I said, that dude go and ball.
Just fucking go bald, you know, so he
makes a joke about it. Yell App. Yeah,
it's fucking awful.
God bless you.
And your full head of hair
and then fucking make fun
of this shirt. There you go.
Um, I hope that helped
out sir. Alright. Alright.
Viking twins and oh, she's
viking twins in Jesus. Bill,
I know you're tired of
relationship advice, but this May,
but maybe this will be
different. Um, here's the deal.
I'm having God damn twins in
September. Wow. Congratulations.
Had been married for nearly six years now.
I love my wife and I'm definitely stoked
on having children with her. However,
while she's a Christian,
I am not and I am a little concerned.
Okay.
And then what he, what
does he write? All fucking
greedy. Oh, fucking ready. He wrote that.
He wrote that all as one word. Everybody.
If you think I'm dumb. And he wrote,
he wrote all his a l and those spaces.
Okay,
stop rolling your eyes feeling
that you're smarter than me. Um,
he says,
I'm a little concerned about what our
kids are going to learn if we decide to go
to church and whatnot.
I'm just not sure that I want my children
to learn about hell and sin and all
that other bullshit.
Um,
that's just not a story for fucking kids.
You know,
like you'll be bet you better
be good or when you fucking die,
you're going to burn for God damn
maternity. I want my kids to be happy.
I don't want them expecting a bitch
slap from some imaginary figure.
If they tell a fucking liar something,
kids should be innocent and full of wonder
and gay and all that shit. You know,
that's so funny.
I'll guys can't just write happy stuff.
You've got to somehow tap out,
you know, they should be happy.
They should go sledding and all that
shit. You fucking cunt. You know,
we always got to do that anyhow.
I'm not exactly sure what Nia believes,
but you guys.
But if you guys had kid,
would this be an issue for you to now
neither one of us goes to church. Um,
another well, so we're
going to go to hey yo. Um,
another problem is that either way sucks.
If they believe in how the live unfair.
If the little shit believe what I believe,
they'll think they're just
going to goddamn rotten,
the fucking ground and disappear
when they die. So there'll be bitter,
cynical and fucking miserable
just like their father.
Now I disagree with that cause I
think you just go onto the ground.
That's what I think.
But that's not why I'm bitter and cynical.
I'm bitter and cynical because of like
that fucking email that I got from that
50 year old real estate guy who wants me
to side with the bank cunts and no one
will pick up an ax and go into these
gated communities and get these pencil
pushing pussies,
you know?
And every fucking week we work,
we got to take our fucking check and
take it down to the Goddamn Bank and give
it to him.
You know,
acting like this is a safer place to
have that stuffing in your mattress.
You know,
you might as well stuffing in a mattress,
you're never going to walk in and your
mattress is going to have a lock on it
and be like, yeah, fuck that's
closed. Go Fuck Yourself.
And I know what other people
saying, well, you know,
yeah.
What if somebody breaks into your house?
Does anybody look under
the mattress at this point?
It's such a cliched place to
put a couple hundred bucks.
You know, I had a fucking know you
can't win. That's why I'm cynical.
That's why I'm cynical.
Okay. Because you know, I,
I'll talk to hockey fans.
Okay.
And they'll have the biggest
dirt bag piece of shit,
intent to injure guy on their team.
But because he plays for them,
they don't give a fuck. And they'll
put them in their ring of honor.
And then if somebody does
something to their team,
then they're flipping out going,
that guy should be out of the league.
That's why I get bitter and
cynical is because it's depressing.
It's depressing that,
that the amount of people that just
look out their own heads and you know,
if it's good for me, then
it's fucking good and I don't
give a shit. And they, uh,
you know,
they lack empathy.
That's what, but now, because you're
going into the fucking ground. So I,
I wouldn't equate it to that. Um, anyways,
my solution thus far is just to go north,
you know?
No,
I don't die and fucking battle
Diane fucking battles sons.
And you'll get to be members of the,
and her, her jar. I Dunno. It's
just some Lord of the rings. Shit,
fight and die every day,
only to be resurrected at night
to faced with Odin and Valhalla.
I don't know what any of this is something
when you and your fellow goes for you
is fight the fucking Wolf
fenrir until the end of time.
That's a Badass speech.
If I knew how to fucking pronounce it.
It's one of those things where you're
walking around with that thing on your arm
for a Falcon, the land on. And
when you go to shake hands,
you grabbed the other guy's forum. Um,
he goes, I think that's the way to go.
I have absolutely no idea how to really
relay these concerns to my wife without
offending her. Yeah. I mean,
considering you're writing me, I get it,
but I think I care enough about
my kids to make this an issue.
My kids are going to be complete,
completely mediocre and
never accomplish anything.
Then there's no need to heat. Oh, what?
My kids are going to be completely
mediocre, never accomplished anything.
There's no need to heap hell on that pile.
What do you think?
All right, well I was with you until you
said your kids are going to be mediocre.
You can't say that to them.
You got to give them that head start.
You've got to build them up and seen.
I got and I got to talk to
you about two things. Um,
I mean, I don't know. You're,
you're really far down the fucking road
six years in and now you're having kids
to finally bring up the religious issue.
This is really something that should have
been discussed before you got married,
but I get it.
You fell in love with this person,
you can't pick who you fall
in love with as they say.
Um,
I,
I would just sit down and tell her what
you told me. And then when she was like,
well, why is you bringing this up
fixed years ago used line I just said,
just say, cause I love you saw. Yeah.
And I, I, there's nothing I could do.
I fell in love with you. I think
you're great. It, you know,
now I just want to discuss this with
you and I'd like to do it without you
crying and making me feel like
a bully because I, I, you know,
these are half my kids too.
So what if once a week, every,
every other week you
scared the shit out of him.
And every other week we go into the
back yard and I dig a hole and go,
that's what he ended up.
You can sort of balance it out.
MMM.
Yeah, do it. I don't know.
I don't know how to do it other than you
just have to sit down and talk to her
and just say, listen, I don't mind
spirituality. I don't mind, you know,
believing in a higher
power and everything,
but I really think it's a lot to heap on
the whole heaven and hell thing and uh,
I think when they're young enough,
when they go to church,
they're just going to be bored and not
know what people are talking about.
And I think it'd be a
great thing for their self.
Esteem's if you and I didn't drive away
and try to communicate all that hell
shit to him.
All right.
Maybe she can still take them to church,
but just keep reinforcing
that this thing loves them.
All right.
That is a fucked up thing to
just bring that into their lives.
You're going to burn forever.
Have Fun. Played Frisbee. Um,
all right. Pro Flowers. Everybody.
Mother's Day is coming up.
Ah. Who's better than your
mom? No one. All right.
Did you give your mom a hard time growing
up? Cause she did because she did.
We like me.
Did you get into a fight with your brother
and went after he slapped you in the
back of the head and you grabbed the
garden hose and you tried to spray at them
through the fucking screen of the
kitchen. You flooded the kitchen, right,
and your mother came out with a wooden
spoon and beat it over your head until
it's snapped in half. Did you do that?
Of course she did. Isn't it time?
Did you take out the car and
wrap it around a pole and
then they got sued by the
family? That fucking makes the
telephone poles. Of course you did.
Don't you think it's time?
Something that may be a,
I think giving me suggestions here.
I know to make it funny.
Oh good.
He suggested is talk about how you're
making up for it by sending her profile.
I'm not going to talk about stuff
that's not going on in my life.
I'm going to talk about the fact that I
love my mom and I love my girlfriend so
I'm going to get them flowers.
Is there an easier way to do it then?
Pro flowers.com absolutely not.
Pro Flowers has one.
Doesn't Rainbow Roses for 1999 or you
can double the roses and get chocolates
plus a premium pig vase for
just 29 98 that's 50% off.
You just need my code burpee.
You are, when you order to
get these special prices,
he got a colorful bouquet of roses.
Or is it both?
K is a bouquet of roses that
will make your mom smile.
This offer is just for my radio listeners.
Um,
it's eliciting or favorite
every year. Come on, man.
You guys got to do more than just send
your mother a card. Women love flowers,
you know,
and she's going to love that you care.
Even though you've gotten older and
your marriage is still remembering,
dear old mom, profiles are guaranteed
to last a full week or your money back.
You know? See if you get us or
a sweater she wears at one day.
She puts it in the drawer. You get it,
the flowers with that beautiful face,
she's going to see them all week.
All right, so here's the deal.
The only way to get this amazing mother's
Day deal is to go to proflowers.com
click on the microphone in the top right
hand corner and type in B, u. R. R.
That's proflowers.com click on the
microphone and type in birth order. Now,
this special pricing expires
soon. Yeah, do it right now.
Just get it out of the way and then
the pressure of Mother's Day. You know,
you're not going to have to worry
about running out, going to cds,
trying to pick out the last
fucking three cards that are left.
You don't want to do that. All right,
so there you go. All right, last read.
Hear everybody. Uh, they
already do this one.
Ah, Jesus. Then, uh, he
voice. Oh, I like this one.
He voices the reasons you're
going to make more money in 2013.
How do you like that for confidence,
right out of the gate with their copy.
They are the reason you're going to make
more money. Uh, when your customers call,
you'll have your own toll free number,
professional greeting,
dial by name directory,
and more.
You'll sound like a fortune 500
company and blow away your competitors.
You'll sound like a fortune 500 company.
Even though you only have three employees.
You could just have one employee and
they'll make you sound like he got this
giant factory already and you're just
somebody getting business with eve.
Voice lets you give out one number
that rings wherever you are. The beach,
the bar doesn't matter. You'll sound
like you're at the office. Yeah.
Unless people are screaming in the
background. I mean we have to go to,
yeah I guess you go into the bathroom.
Um,
you got to go to he voice.com and use
the Promo Code Bill. Ie voice takes,
oh he voice even takes
all your voicemails,
transcribes them and sends them to you
instantly as a text or an email so you
can check your voicemails before
the meeting ends and not look rude.
Eve Voice is only 10 bucks
a month for a long time.
And listeners have been
able to get free tiles,
free Tarot of he voice for six months.
But that's about to come to an end. Okay.
So guys,
make sure you sign up for your free trial
of the voice between now and the end
of the month,
which is literally tomorrow.
And get your six months free trial
before it's too late. Come on guys.
I want you to get you out of them
cubicles if you want. All right,
it's your last chance to try this
great service for free for six months.
Go to [inaudible] dot com use
the Promo code bill that's evil.
[inaudible] dot com Promo code bill,
or just go to the podcast page on
[inaudible] dot com and click on the voice
banner right now. All
right, there you go. Okay,
back to the podcast.
And what better way to go back to the
podcast by reading this lovely email,
this lovely email right here called
getting cock blocked by Jesus. You know,
gee,
um,
that would be became walking in
performing miracles. Full head of hair,
Chris Christopherson beard. You know,
it's got that robe. All the check thought.
My God, you have anything
underneath it. Um, hate bell.
Love the podcast.
I really relate to hear your thoughts on
this experience I'm going through with
a lady.
Okay.
All right. At the end of last summer, I
met a girl and we hit it off immediately.
She's one of those girls, oh wait, I
forgot to add, I forgot to mention that a,
I'm going to do a Nia log this week and
Nia log and I in a lot of people are
asking why is she not doing her podcast?
And it's because our house is gutted
right now and she's been an absolute
trooper and she's handling most of the
bullshit as I'm out on the road. Okay.
But she's going to come on and
do a Neil Ogg this weekend.
One of the topics is going to be the
first openly gay athlete. All right.
I'm going to, I'm actually going to ask
her that question about the shower. Um,
shower love.
Every now and then I get a little bit
something in or something and then or
something. Um, at the end of last summer,
back to this guy cock block by, hey Seuss.
I met a girl and we
hit it off immediately.
She's one of those girls who's
not only gorgeous and sexy,
but she's really cool
too. Oh, top shelf. Uh,
we've got a lot in common
and I'm totally into her.
I've seen her regularly since then
and she stayed with me a few nights.
We've had apps.
We've had absolutely mind blowing
sex during those nights. Ah,
Jesus, dude, you're gonna fall hard for
this one. I'm already in love with her.
I don't even know her.
Uh,
but most importantly we have fun together
and we connect on a personal level.
So I decided to take it to the next level
and see if she'd be into dating on a
wreck on the regular since we've
been hitting it off so well,
that's when it gets interesting.
She says she is a Christian.
I on the other hand,
am definitely not a Christian,
although I've studied religious
writings for many years.
I don't consider myself to be a religious
person, but since I'm not a Christian,
she's really reluctant to date.
But you'll fuck your brains out,
dude. I Dunno man. I think he, he
might just have to enjoy this one.
You know, it's like renting
a car. You can't afford
to go out and take it on the highway,
man.
Have a good time with it and bring it
back by Thursday. Um, but whatever,
I'll keep reading here.
The Bible says Christian should
only date other Christians.
The Bible says a lot of things that
don't make sense in society. Now. Uh,
my mother is a Catholic and my
father is non religious as I am,
but they've been happily
married for almost 30 years.
It irritates the hell out of me
that since I don't love Jesus,
that she thinks I'm an unsuitable partner.
I don't need to love Jesus to know
how to be a good gentlemen. Um,
I treat her with respect and I'm a good
partner and a friend. What do you think,
Bill? Literally everything else about
this girl and how we get along is stellar.
It's a fucking shame to let that go.
Thanks, Bill. And Go fuck yourself. Um,
where's the deal?
I would present your argument and if she
still has a fucking problem with it and
she just won't do it,
then you know what you gotta do.
You gotta walk away until your heart
gets crushed by this girl. Or even worse,
you talk her into something by just
wearing or down into something she doesn't
want to do.
And then you six years into your fucking
marriage having twins like that other
poor bastard and you have
to have that other problem,
that big fucking conversation.
Okay.
She's getting older so you know
she's going to have a couple of kids,
she's not going to be rocky and you're
fucking world. You know what I mean?
You got a beer belly,
so all the looks and all the hot sex is
out the window and now you just fucking
with this person all right,
that you don't line up with
religiously. So that, that's,
that is a big one. That is a big
one. So that's what I would do.
I would sit down and I would
present my argument to her and
just lay it out there. Just say, listen,
I really like you beyond a physical thing.
I like you,
you know,
and I'd bring up the thing he said about
your parents and they still get along
and then just say,
well look,
I don't want to get emotionally involved
with you if you can't look past the
fact that I don't believe
in the bearded baby. Um,
and that's how I'd leave it.
And then,
you know what if she has a fucking
problem with that, then you walk,
you walk,
all right?
Or what you do is just hook up with
her once every fucking 10 days,
10 to 15 days, you hook up with
her, you fuck her brains out,
you have a great time, and then you
know, you, you walk away, you know,
so you don't get drawn in.
Like,
I dunno, be with somebody
else. It's like a,
the more you see him, it's like
fucking eating Doritos. You know,
if you just take a few and you put them
on a plate and then you leave the bag in
the cupboard and you're watching a game,
you know,
you're not going to get up and
go grab the bag. All right?
But if fucking got the bag there,
you're going to consume the whole goddamn
thing and that's what the fuck are you
gonna do with this girl? If you keep
hanging out with her, all right,
you're going to consume
the whole fucking thing.
You're going to be totally invested with
the heart and then she's going to walk
away because you don't want to get fucking
dirty fire ash put on your forehead
every fucking February.
Then you can be crying in the fetal
position and you've got to spend fucking
goddamn year or two of your life trying
to cry this bitch out of your heart.
You know what I mean? Sit Down and have
this conversation with the, there you go.
All right. Netflix documentaries. A bill.
Just let's do the a recent podcast in
the podcast you mentioned that you like
documentaries. I love him.
I absolutely love them.
Documentaries are like reading
for stupid people. You know,
you get this like watching a book,
unless you watched those Michael Moore
ones or that one that that guy made about
Nirvana. You know what I mean? Like
what Michael Morris should be like,
considered video like op ed pieces.
MMM.
You know, I, I, and you can, it's easy
to tell. I hate to single that guy out,
but that guy I think is one of the biggest
offenders of somebody who's just like
already has his mind made up and his
editing around the opinion that he already
has and he's just, you know, taking you
by the hand and leading you down to this.
Absolutely fucking so
ridiculous to one side.
That guy to me is as ridiculous as
fucking bill O'Reilly. You know, I,
I'd actually say he's more ridiculous
that bill O'Reilly, you know what I mean?
Anyways, I don't like, don't like
talking politics. Here we go. Um,
now I know you say you
don't like football, soccer,
but I know you love this.
But yeah,
I know you'll love this.
It's called the four year plan and it's
about a team called Queens Park Rangers.
They had just been taken over
by a team of billionaires,
including big names in Formula
One. I love, by the way,
I love Formula One racing.
I never watch it. I always miss it.
I always somehow the seasons weird,
it starts in like February or some
shit. I don't know. I, I always miss it,
but formula one racing is like if
you're ever going to meet James Bond,
it's going to be at a
formula formula one race.
Like you're just talking the
richest people on the planet,
the greatest bone structures of any
people you're ever going to see.
Nothing but full heads of jet black hair
and some of the hottest ass you're ever
going to see in your life.
They're at these things.
It's insane.
And then what I love about this sport is,
is the level of intelligence to get that
car just go just a little bit faster.
And then it also makes sense. It's
as right and left turns, you know,
and they race in the rain. It's re,
it's re, it's the real fucking deal.
I'm a huge fan of it.
By all means.
Somebody let me know when
the next Formula One races.
It's not like I can't go on the
Internet and find out I had,
was it the fuel channel?
I know somebody shows them.
I always wanted to get
that in just one year.
Just follow it for the whole fucking year,
you know,
Ferrari team and all those fucking
Mercedes and all those great car
manufacturers. Anyways, here we go.
Somehow someone persuaded these Formula
One people to allow a TV crew to record
everything, which is basically them
owning this, uh, this soccer club.
I'm in a nutshell. It turns out to
show exactly how not to run a club.
Spoiler alert. Here we go. This document,
he may change how you see football.
By the way, I'm from Birmingham, England,
England, and I support Aston Villa.
My apologies because I know
I probably said that wrong.
I really don't know why I've told you
this, but please watch it. It's fantastic.
Oh, absolutely. I would, I would
love to watch that. I'd watch one on,
on a world cup soccer.
I,
I like World Cup soccer that the whole
world is watching and it really is a
world championship when you win it,
you know,
those fucking horns that they were
blowing. That really blew it for me. Uh,
last time I remember trying to watch it,
I was in Vegas with Tom Papa and,
uh,
he had this show at the Orleans
and it was me and him doing this,
this comedy show.
I was such a fucking great weekend.
So I brought the lovely Nia with me and
we both went up to his suite and we were
watching, I was actually
psyched that I found on another,
an American that was into the soccer and
we were sitting there watching it and
that stupid fucking horns
being blown the entire time.
It just became, this running joke is he's
Tom started imitating, just kept going,
crap,
I have to have that.
I can't remember some sort of Jerry
Lewis kind of fucking noise and we would
just be trying to focus on the game.
And every three minutes one of us would
do our impression of those horns and
somehow it stayed funny for the
entire fucking match. And uh, but
that really, that really hurt
the World Cup. Like those,
those horns should be
banned. So anyways, whatever,
whatever I'm saying I'm going to watch
that one. Did you say what it was called?
Yeah, you did. It's called the four year
plan. I'm definitely gonna Watch that.
All right. Hey, Billy boy.
Just wanted to give you a couple of good
documentaries to watch on Netflix. Oh,
look at me. I think I hit
it. I hit a nerve. I hit an
artery. People are enjoying.
Um, just wanted to give you a couple of
good documentaries to watch on Netflix.
I am the first one. The imposter
is a really good one. Also,
the wild and wonderful whites of West
Virginia is absolutely hilarious.
You know,
I started to watch that one and
it's really fascinating,
but that there's,
there's something about watching
people who are poor at a certain point,
poor and uneducated.
I have to shut it off because it,
it feels like a, I dunno,
it's like watching that dead.
Here comes honey booboo.
I started to watch an
episode of it and you know,
it was kind of laughing along and
everything, but when they went to the,
that auction and they were,
they were basically auctioning off food
that grocery stores couldn't legally
sell. You know, it was kind of
past the expiration date or,
and they would, they were bidding
on like old cookies and shit.
Now there's no way they couldn't have
been meet because you could kill somebody.
So I know that maybe
it was something about,
it was food that the grocery
stores couldn't sell.
People so broke that they were buying,
they were bidding on week old cookies.
Yeah.
And then like high fiving and
excited when they won the auction.
Like they just bought a fucking Shelby or
something. I have to shut it off. So, uh,
but it is fascinating.
Um, what the other one is,
he said one more is called unguarded.
The story of Chris Herren heroin.
I don't know how to say it. He,
he was a bad ass high school basketball
player out of Boston who through his
career, away on drugs. Um,
that's another rough one to why I
liked watching the ones where people,
they win in the end, you know,
but I'll watch that when he says,
love the podcast and you stand
up. Go Fuck Yourself. All right,
that is the podcast for this
week. Everybody, uh, I hope
you enjoyed it. And, um,
I have to tell you,
man,
this was one of the most amazing
months in my standup career.
All these beautiful venues
that I got to perform in.
It's really a blessing to be able to
do standup at Ed at a theater. And,
um,
I wanted to thank everybody that that is,
that has come out to my shows this month.
Then I really learned something this
month about all these so called B and c
level cities like the,
they're the shit. And um,
you know, people are so
fucking appreciative when you
come out to him, you know,
I'm not talking like Dallas and
Austin and that type of thing.
I'm talking about when you go
to like Tallahassee, you know,
it's so ridiculous. I guess last week I
kept calling to Columbia, but Charleston,
South Carolina that I went to,
I mean that's an a level city.
They'd like fucking houses with
$9 million right on the water.
But like, just people don't go to them.
Um, we actually, I know what that,
I mentioned that I was going to do a
tour of Canada and we were going to do it
in the summertime and we realized
how stupid that was. That uh,
you know, you know, I've done
a lot of stuff for the NHL, um,
going on their radio show and everything
really if we really need to promote
this thing because I haven't toured Canada
and I don't want to be in front of 40
people every show.
So we took that tour,
we moved it to January of 2014 during
hockey season where I can actually promote
the thing. So I don't go
to fucking thunder bay and
stand in front of two people,
but so that's kind of a bad thing
if you wanted me to come to Canada.
So I apologize because I know
I said I was going to be there,
but we are putting together
a tour of all these,
the flyover states in
place of that in July.
And uh, some of the dates are
going to be like Boise, Idaho.
I know I got a date or two in Montana,
the last state I need to,
to go to. Then I've been to all 50. Uh,
I remember hearing deadwood,
Kansas, I think Oklahoma,
some places in Colorado that aren't
Denver because I always go to the comedy
works.
So I'm going to try to get out there and
maybe do another bus tour and hit all
these places that, um, that I've
never been to. And you know,
I have people come up to me at the end of
my shows go, man. I, I drove four hours.
I drove six hours and like these insane,
I drove here from fucking Iowa and uh,
you know,
so I think it's about time that I
fucking drove out to where they're at.
So that's going to be happening in July.
I'll let you guys know about the
dates as soon as they get solidified.
And once again,
thank you to everybody came,
this is how fucking great this toy was.
I actually, you know, I ended up in, um,
in Kansas City at the Midland theater
and the promoters girlfriend made all
these cookies with my name on them.
It said,
the Midland theater
thanking me for coming.
That was one of the nicest fucking
things anybody has ever done,
um, for me. And you know, it's so
funny, I had such a fucking sweet tooth.
She made like 20 of them.
I took them all home.
It's stuck him in my luggage and a,
some of them broke,
but I was such a sweet tooth.
I put them in this fucking Tupperware,
even poured the crumbs in there. So, uh,
my battle for it of not being old Billy
fat face, I'm fucking losing it. But uh,
so, and as much as I appreciated
that please somebody else,
don't do it to me because I'll become a
tub of shit if somebody gives me cookies
after every fucking show cause I'll,
I'll eat all of them.
It's an embarrassing weakness
that I have. Um, all right,
that's the podcast for this week. Um,
for people who want to get into the NHL,
the NHL playoffs start tomorrow,
I believe April 30th.
And I'm going to fucking,
I'm ride or die with my Bruins and I'm
hoping just something because it's the
playoffs that they can somehow put
together three good periods. Uh,
I don't give a fuck. I'll always watch
him. I love him. Go Fuck Yourself.
That's the podcast. I'll
see you next week. There.